lockerungen von nord bis süd die zahl
der korona ansteckungen sinkt die
bundesländer nehmen immer mehr
beschränkungen zurück widerspruch aus
karlsruhe das bundesverfassungsgericht
stellt sich gegen die europäische
zentralbank und ihren kauf von
staatsanleihen und ruf nach staatshilfe
die autobranche fordert kaufprämien für
neuwagen die bundesregierung will aber
noch beraten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind
jetzt geht es plötzlich überraschend
schnell zwar sprechen kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten erst morgen über
weitere lockerungen doch mehr und mehr
bundesländer geben schon jetzt
entsprechende pläne bekannt von bayern
über sachsen anhalt bis nach schleswig
holstein aus der wissenschaft also vom
robert koch institut kommt folgende
einschätzung
er rechnet zwar fest mit einer zweiten
ansteckungswelle zeigt sich insgesamt
aber zuversichtlich wir haben uns ja
einen großartigen erfolg zusammen
erkämpft das muss man so sagen und wenn
wir den gut verteidigen dann werden die
zahlen niedrig bleiben und das muss das
ziel sein das heißt also wir sollten
immer wachsam sein und immer die abstand
regeln einhalten also abstand halten ist
sicher der neue alltag und der wird dann
dazu beitragen dass die infektionszahlen
niedrig bleiben lka-chef wieder sagt
auch man müsse immer die regionalen
unterschiede berücksichtigen und die
sind gewaltig die wenigsten infizierten
703 gibt es in mecklenburg vorpommern
die meisten in bayern aktuell mehr als
43.000 beide bundesländer haben
weitreichende lockerungen angekündigt
zuerst der blick nach bayern
dort dürfen übernächste woche sogar
biergärten wieder öffnen aus münchen
jürgen bollmann
münchen wiener platz nach wochen
strenger ausgangs beschränkungen
erleichterung aber auch eine spürbare
erschöpfung bei vielen menschen weil ich
so langsam merke dass die luft raus ist
so in der ganzen familie irgendwann kann
man auch nicht mehr so motiviert das
ganze machen wie man es vielleicht noch
in den ersten wochen gemacht hat oder
vor allen dingen in der ersten woche in
bayern war besuch in einer anderen
wohnung verboten
ich kann meine mutter besuchen das ist
eine herzens geschichte und ist wirklich
in ordnung
trotzdem die staatsregierung bleibt bei
ihrem vorsichtigen kurs lockerungen jahr
aber immer etwas weniger und etwas
später als die anderen bundesländern
trotz der optimistischen einschätzung
des ministerpräsidenten
warum ist die zeit jetzt richtig weil
die erfolge eindeutig sichtbar waren
jetzt ist corona unter kontrolle
auf die strenge bayerische ausgangs
beschränkung folgt eine sogenannte
kontakt beschränkung also abstand halten
gruppenbildung verboten
auch für krankenhäuser und altenheime
werden die besuchsmöglichkeiten nur ein
wenig gelockert
spielplätze werden morgen wieder
freigegeben biergärten dürfen am 18 mai
öffnen lokale aber die türen erst eine
woche später aufsperren große freude und
große sorgen wenn wir jetzt hier den
abstand halten müssen natürlich und wenn
wir dann nur noch die hälfte an gäste
schicken können
es kommen wir keine wirtschaftlichkeit
also wir werden unsere kosten nicht
wagen können
ab nächsten montag dürfen in bayern auch
geschäfte die mehr als 800 quadratmeter
groß sind öffnen unter strengen auflagen
er hätte natürlich nicht länger laufen
dürfen ein lock down sowie ich habe ihn
so noch nie erlebt
das hat aber auch schon vorher auch noch
keiner erlebt die bayerische
staatsregierung fürchtet eine zweite
virus fälle sollte es nötig werden wer
die lockerungen auch wieder
zurückgenommen so markus söder und jetzt
nach mecklenburg vorpommern das land in
dem sich bundesweit die wenigsten
menschen infiziert haben wirtschaftlich
noch wichtiger als in bayern ist dort
der tourismus entsprechend groß die
erleichterung des bald restaurants und
hotels wieder öffnen dürfen
susanne seidel peter weide und sein team
vom restaurant vielmehr aus kühlungsborn
sind überrascht dass sie schon samstag
wieder öffnen dürfen dann gab es eine
telefonkonferenz gestern abend noch um
elf mit all unseren lieferanten die ich
dann ja zum teil sogar geweckt hatte
auch die sind ja überrascht worden
aber es beschwert sich natürlich keiner
weil wir wollten es so unter druck war
groß es überwiegt die freude und wir
sind wir sind vorbereitet
tische für maximal sechs erwachsene
kontaktdaten müssen erfasst abstände
eingehalten werden das personal trägt
mundschutz so hofft peter weide endlich
mit seinem restaurant wieder
durchstarten zu können aufatmen in
mecklenburg vorpommern rund 130.000
arbeitsplätze hängen hier vom tourismus
ab ministerpräsidentin schwesig
verteidigt die lockerungen mit blick auf
die niedrigsten infektionszahlen
bundesweit und aus sorge um den
tourismus wirtschaftsfaktor nummer eins
im nordosten
ich möchte dass unser land corona vivus
übersteht das aber auch unserer
arbeitsplätze und unserer unternehmen
corona virus überstehen in der
bevölkerung trifft das auf
unterschiedliche gefühle haben wir
wieder ein bisschen freizeit zu steigen
wenn vorsichtig gelockert wird und
ausprobiert innen geht es in ordnung ist
verfrüht
ich bin selbst getroffen weil ich
risikogruppe will und dessen ist sich
der frage noch mit anderen augen müssen
also eine hätte sagte kann nicht
passieren
auch campingplätze ferienwohnungen
pensionen und hotels wie das von anne
jakob aus kühlungsborn dürfen ab dem 18
wieder für mecklenburger und vorpommern
öffnen die freude ist groß doch schon
das frühstück wird zur corona zeiten
eine herausforderung statt buffet gibt
es service am tisch das ist natürlich
personalintensiver dennoch freuen wir
uns über die möglichkeit überhaupt den
gast etwas anbieten zu dürfen
kopfzerbrechen macht ihr jedoch die
tatsache dass die hotels nur bis zu 60
prozent ausgelastet sein dürfen
wem soll sie da absagen wenn ab dem 25
mai wieder alle gäste aus ganz
deutschland anreisen dürfen männer die
in berlin was kann bei dem gespräch
morgen noch rauskommen wenn jetzt schon
so viele länder nägel mit köpfen machen
ja vor allem noch mal eine gemeinsame
marschrichtung der jetzt zwischen all
diesen ankündigungen doch eher verloren
geht auf der tagesordnung steht auf
jeden fall ein klarer fahrplan für
schulen kitas und den sport also auch
den fußball
da liegen schon entsprechende konzepte
vor hoffnung machen können sich auch
gastronomen und hoteliers das morgen
doch noch einmal ausführlich gesprochen
wird über eine klare perspektive für
gastronomie und tourismus und die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundeskanzlerin werden sicherlich auch
noch einmal darüber sprechen wie man
eigentlich vorgeht wenn man jetzt so
viele öffnungen hat und dann das virus
an der ein oder anderen stelle
zurückkommen sollte also wie dann
möglicherweise wieder beschränkungen
eingeführt werden können was sagt das
denn über die machtverhältnisse aus wenn
sich jetzt kaum ein landeschef mehr an
die absprachen der bundeskanzlerin hielt
was ist zeigt auf jeden fall dass die
bundeskanzlerin wieder die macht noch
die mittel hat um die
ministerpräsidenten auf eine linie zu
zwingen sie hat ja immer darauf gepocht
dass man gemeinsam und besonnen vorgeht
und auch kommuniziert dass davon hatte
sie die ministerpräsidenten auch
überzeugt in der ersten sitzung hat man
das gemeinsam beschlossen aber die
ministerpräsidentinnen sind ihr von der
fahne gegangen und machen jetzt eben
doch ihre eigenen entscheidungen in den
bundesländern auch markus söder der
bisher immer sehr eng an ihrer seite
gestanden hat und gesagt hat wir müssen
alles gemeinsam abstimmen
hat ja heute in bayern eigene neue
regelungen angekündigt also da zeigt
sich dass man die bundesländer nicht
zwingen kann das ist zwar föderalismus
aber für angela merkel eine kleine
niederlage in der gemeinsamen linie
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
berlin schock und albert ii und jetzt
nochmal die genauen zahlen von heute zur
verdeutlichung nehmen wir bei den
neuansteckungen den durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage
und da geht der trend weiter nach unten
so sind es heute nur noch 1060
infektionen pro tag insgesamt sind
aktuell mehr als 166.000 corona fälle
durch tests bestätigt davon gelten rund
135.000 betroffene wieder als genesen
6993 menschen starben in verbindung mit
coop 19
in jedem bundesland gibt es fast täglich
änderungen der chor ohne beschränkungen
welche das sind das haben wir auf der
zdf heute app für sie zum nachlesen
zusammengefasst um den euro und die
wirtschaft in der eben zu stabilisieren
pumpt die europäische zentralbank seit
jahren massenweise geld in die märkte
aber dass sie das überhaupt ja hatte der
europäische gerichtshof gesagt jetzt
aber die überraschung das
bundesverfassungsgericht nennt den
ankauf teilweise verfassungswidrig
seit 2015 hat die ezb rund 2,6 billionen
euro in staatsanleihen und andere
wertpapiere gesteckt mit folgen für fast
jeden sparer bekommen kaum noch zinsen
die immobilien
diese stiegen rentenversicherungen
bringen weniger geld zu dem heutigen
urteil und seinen folgen christoph
schneider als die richterinnen und
richter des zweiten senats am vormittag
wegen der korona einschränkungen nur zu
fünft den sitzungssaal betreten haben
sie historisches zu verkünden erstmals
in seiner geschichte stellt das
bundesverfassungsgericht fest dass
handlung und entscheidung europäische
organe offensichtlich nicht von der
europäischen kompetenzordnung gedeckt
sind und daher in deutschland keine
wirksamkeit entfalten können und seiner
kritik haben die richterinnen und
richter weitgehend rechnung getragen
peter gauweiler
für ihn seien demokratische
mitwirkungsrechte der bürger über jahre
von bundesregierung und bundestag
verletzt worden
es ist heute festgestellt worden dass
die europäische bankdirektoren schecks
ausgestellt haben die nicht gedeckt
waren die nicht den regeln ihrer eigenen
bank gefolgt haben und dass sie sich
dagegen zur wehr setzen können
das prinzip der kritisierten
staatsanleihenkäufe wenn ein staat sich
geld leihen will bietet er
staatsanleihen an
die ezb kann sie ihn nicht abkaufen denn
sie darf einzelnen staaten kein geld
geben
deshalb kaufen andere die staatsanleihen
banken zum beispiel die ihren risiko ist
dabei gering denn sie können die papiere
weiter verkaufen an die ezb auf diesem
weg landet dann doch das geld der
zentralbank in der staatskasse
das prinzip grundsätzlich in ordnung
aber bei dem 2015 gestarteten
kaufprogramm habe die notenbank ihr
mandat für die geldpolitik überspannt so
das verfassungsgericht
der finanzminister hat verstanden eins
ist ganz klar wir werden wege finden wie
das notwendige was in europa geschehen
muss auch in zukunft geschehen kann dazu
hat das bundesverfassungsgericht eine
sehr klare linie vorgegeben und im
übrigen auch viel zeit
künftig muss die ezb schaden und nutzen
ihre politik besser abwägen
tut sie das nicht muss sie die deutsche
bundesbank die gefolgschaft verweigern
sarah tacke ist bei mir die leiterin
unserer rechts redaktion
sarah welcher sprengstoff steckt in
diesem urteil
der sprengstoff die historische
dimension ist der fakt dass noch nie
innerhalb der europäischen union ein
verfassungsgericht dem europäischen
gerichtshof in dieser form die
gefolgschaft untersagt versagt hat und
das bundesverfassungsgericht ist nicht
irgendein verfassungsgericht sondern es
ist das wahrscheinlich mächtigste
einflussreichste angesehenste innerhalb
der eu und welche folgen welche
auswirkungen diese entscheidung hat das
lässt sich heute nur erahnen klar ist
die institution europäischer gerichtshof
des geschwächt und das kräfteverhältnis
innerhalb der europäischen rechtsordnung
das hat sich verschoben
jetzt stecken wir mitten in der korona
krise die staaten brauchen viel geld
welche folgen hat das urteil jetzt jetzt
gerade also die finanzmärkte die börsen
haben heute sehr gelassen reagiert und
das liegt daran dass sie wissen dass es
kurzfristig keine konsequenzen hat und
das liegt daran das ist ganz zentral
ganz wichtig die verfassungsrichter
haben heute deutlich gesagt dass
aktuelle staatsanleihekaufprogramm das
aufgelegt wurde wegen der korona
pandemie um den euroraum zu
stabilisieren 750 milliarden euro schwer
das ist unberührt von dieser
entscheidung das läuft weiter erinnert
sich nichts aber mittel und langfristig
wird die ezb nicht mehr weitermachen
können wie bisher weil die
verfassungsrichter sehr deutlich gesagt
haben sie müssen die negativen folgen
ihrer anleihenkauf politik mit bedenken
negative folgen für die sparer auf der
einen seite vermögensverschiebung hinzu
aktionären immobilienbesitzer eine
mögliche immobilienblase all diese
risiken und nebenwirkungen der
anleihenkaufprogramme müssen in zukunft
mit bedacht werden und die ezb muss dann
im zweifel ich ihre politik des billigen
geldes auch korrigieren oder auch ein
zweiter beenden
sarah attacke über ein historisches
urteil vielen dank wenn die
autoindustrie hustet dann hat
deutschland die grippe so hieß es schon
vor corona sie ist gemessen am umsatz
die bedeutendste industrie hierzulande
die branche erwirtschaftet rund 400
milliarden euro umsatz direkt
beschäftigt sie mehr als 800.000
menschen und hat ohnehin schon zu
kämpfen mit dem umstieg auf
elektroantrieb und dem misstrauen
nachdem diesel skandal und jetzt noch
corona vier wochen standen die bänder
still
beim autogipfel heute forderten die
manager staatliche hilfe oliver deuker
es tut sich wieder was in den deutschen
automobilwerken nachdem die bänder
corona bedingt stillstanden
zwar verzeichnete die branche schon seit
anfang des jahres beträchtliche
auftragsrückgänge mit dem lockdown mitte
märz dann der absturz ins bodenlose
wir haben eine tiefe rezession und es
hängt jetzt entscheidend davon ab ob es
uns gelingt aus dieser rezession
herauszukommen
deshalb brauchen wir unterstützungen
unterstützung die die menschen wieder
arbeit gibt und die verhindern kann dass
es zu entlassungen kommt so machen sich
die branche und die betroffenen länder
chefs für weitere kaufprämien stark die
forderungen 4000 euro beim neukauf eines
fahrzeugs mit elektro brennstoffzelle
oder plug in hybridantrieb 3000 euro für
einen modernen verbrenner protest
deshalb vor dem kanzleramt in dem sich
angela merkel einige minister
gewerkschafter und autohersteller teils
per video konferenz dazu austauschten
das ist irrsinnig ist ganz zu schweigen
von ökologischen aspekten dass das
gewagte drin thematisiert wird skandal
die kaufprämien vorschläge der
autohersteller zahlreiche
wirtschaftsexperten kritisieren
ebenfalls sinn und wirkung der idee ich
würde sagen man versucht hier maximales
herauszuholen und hat nur antworten der
vergangenheit und nicht für die zukunft
insbesondere wenn auch noch fossile
verbrennungsmotoren gefördert werden
sollen weil das ist ökonomisch unsinnig
und klimapolitisch falsche bewegung vor
dem kanzleramt drinnen eher verhaltenen
reaktionen zu den vorschlägen der
autobauer die in den vergangenen jahren
gut verdienten wenn firmen staatliche
rettungshilfe benötigen um überleben zu
können dann dürfen sie
selbstverständlich keine boni
ausschütten und müssen auch ihre manager
und vorstand gehälter entsprechend
anpassen
aber hier geht es um etwas anderes die
maßnahmen die wir anfang juni
beschließen wollen
zielen darauf ab unsere wirtschaft
insgesamt in schwung zu bringen mögliche
kaufanreize finanziert aus steuergeldern
einen durchmarsch für die autoindustrie
wird es nicht wie der autoindustrie
geholfen werden kann dazu mehr in einem
zdf spezial gleich nach und
versendung heute startete auch ein
weiteres kapitel im diesel skandal da
hatten sich viele vw kunden mit dem
konzern ja schon in einem vergleich auf
entschädigung geeinigt andere haben auf
schadensersatz geklagt und die können
weiter hoffen denn in einer vorläufigen
einschätzung sagt der bundesgerichtshof
kunden sei durch die eingebaute abgas
software ein schaden entstanden ein
urteil ist das noch nicht
seit heute verhandelt der bgh erstmals
über die schadensersatzklage eines vw
kunden der autofahrer fordert für seinen
2014 gekauften gebrauchtwagen den vollen
kaufpreis zurück vw habe ihn vorsätzlich
geschädigt allein in deutschland gibt es
rund 68.000 klagen jetzt noch eine
überraschende personalie aus der spd
fraktion ihr haushaltsexperte johannes
kahrs verlässt mit sofortiger wirkung
den bundestag und tritt von allen
politischen ämtern zurück hintergrund
ist ganz offenbar die entscheidung der
fraktionsspitze nicht chaos sondern eva
högl als neue wehrbeauftragte des
bundestags vorzuschlagen chaos erklärte
er wäre gern wehrbeauftragte geblieben
akzeptiere aber die entscheidung für
hügel chaos gilt auch als führender kopf
im seeheimer kreis der den eher
konservativen flügel der spd vertritt
keine 65 tage habe es gedauert um beim
flugaufkommen wieder auf dem niveau von
1955 angekommen zu sein so lufthansa
chef carsten spohr heute bitte sei das
sagt er und niederschmetternd die durch
die korona krise schwer gebeutelte
airline braucht staatliche hilfe der
staat solle sich aber nicht einmischen
fordert spur eines der brennendsten
themen auf der hauptversammlung heute
stefan schlosser berichtet fast alle
maschinen der lufthansa flotte am boden
statt 350 tausend passagiere fliegen
jetzt nur noch 3000 am tag mit dem
kranich aus eigener kraft das
unternehmen die zeit der stillstands
nicht überstehen
unverschuldet brauchen wir staatliche
unterstützung
wir brauchen keine staatliche
geschäftsführung hilfe vom staat ja
einmischung nein bis zu zehn milliarden
euro sind im gespräch in form von
krediten und beteiligungen
dafür wollen teile der politik in
zukunft ein wörtchen mitreden wie das
aussehen könnte zeigt frankreich als
gegenleistung für milliarden vom staat
soll air france nachhaltiger werden und
zb auf inlandsflüge verzichten wenn die
strecke mit der bahn in weniger als
zweieinhalb stunden zu schaffen ist der
start sei aber nie der bessere
unternehmer meinen viele
es ist in der tat bei einer
staatsbeteiligung darauf zu achten dass
unternehmerische entscheidung trotzdem
getroffen werden ohne irgendwelche
parteipolitischen themen in den
vordergrund zu schieben oder eben ein
dogma an der stelle hinzustellen wichtig
ist dass das management weiterhin
schnelle entscheidungen treffen kann
harte einschnitte werden nötig seien
nach der krise wird die lufthansa
kleiner sein als zuvor weniger flugzeuge
weniger arbeitsplätze
dennoch sei das geld gut angelegt die
lufthansa habe weiter eine zukunft das
liegt daran dass die fluggesellschaft
vor corona erfolgreich war weltweit mit
führend dass die technologisch
hervorragend unterwegs war immer neue
flugzeuge gekauft hat und weltweiten
flugverkehr mit arbeitsplätzen in
deutschland angeboten hat die chancen
stehen gut dass die lufthansa nach
corinna wieder durchstartet und die
staatshilfe dann zurückzahlt mit zinsen
schnell noch die korrektur eines
versprechers eben johannes kahrs hat den
bundestag verlassen weil er nicht weil
er bundeswehrbeauftragte gerne geworden
wäre er war es noch nicht
bitte entschuldigen sie dass die korona
die flüge wegen corona annulliert aus
der geplanten auslandsreise wird nichts
dafür so der plan der bundesregierung
sollte es gutscheine geben
doch daraus wird nichts die eu
kommission sagt nein zu deutschlands
plänen
reisende müssten das recht haben auf
eine erstattung der kosten zu bestehen
um das leisten zu können stellt die
regierung den veranstaltern jetzt
zuschüsse in aussicht
wer in diesen zeiten heiraten will mit
gästen hat ganz schlechte karten es sei
denn er tut's in düsseldorf die stadt
hat ein autokino kürzeren zum standesamt
umgewandelt zur großen freude des
brautpaares angehörige und freunde
durften mit dabei sein mit abstand
natürlich in ihren autos das ja-wort
wurde gebührend mit konzert gefeiert
[Applaus]
ein hoch auf kreative beamte die sowas
möglich machen das wetter noch auch der
regen an den alpen lässt nach und es
wird überall ziemlich sonnig die details
hat gleich unter tier claus kleber
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn im heute
journal
hier übernimmt morgen christian sievers
danke für ihr interesse und ihren
zuspruch haben sie noch einen schönen
abend und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
keine liebe zuschauer es wird morgen
kaum wärmer bei uns die luft ist noch
frisch und kalt das merken wir nachts
klarer himmel über deutschland nur an
den alpen regnet bis morgen früh weiter
und es wird verbreitet frostig bis -3
grad mit bodenfrost muss man fast
überall rechnen nur an den küsten im
südwesten bleibt es milder morgen die
temperaturen ähnlich wie heute meist
zwischen 15 und 18 grad 20 am oberrhein
naja und an den küsten immer noch etwas
frischer aber scheint überall die sonne
morgen höchstens mal ein paar dichtere
wolken an der oder und hauses gibt es
und der wind ist nur im norden an den
küsten kräftig kommt aus nordwesten es
wird wärmer in den nächsten tagen auch
sonnig samstag tauchen dann im süd
westen erste schauer und gewitter auf
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut